you've uh you've talked to elon quite a
bit you've written the bottom quite a
bit
just
it'd be cool to to hear you
talk about what are your ideas of what
you know the magic sauces you've written
about about with elon what what makes
him so successful his style of thinking
his ambition his dreams his um the
people he connects with the kind of
problems he tackles is there kind of
comments you can make about what makes
them special i think that obviously
there's a lot of things that he's very
good at he has um he's he has
he's obviously super intelligent his
heart is very much in like i think the
right place like you know i really
really believe that like
and i think people can sense that you
know he just doesn't
seem like a grifter of any kind he's
truly trying to do these big things for
the right reasons
and he's obviously crazy ambitious and
hard-working right not everyone is some
people are as talented and have cool
visions but they just don't want to
spend their life that way so but that's
none of those alone is what makes elon
elon i mean if it were there'd be more
of him because there's a lot of people
that are very smart and smart enough to
accumulate a lot of money and influence
and they have great ambition and they
have you know their hearts in the right
place
um to me it is the very unusual quality
he has is that he's sane in a way that
almost every human is crazy
what i mean by that is we are programmed
to
trust
conventional wisdom over our own
reasoning
um for good reason
if you go back 50 000 years
uh and conventional wisdom says you know
don't eat that berry you know or this is
the way you tire tie a spearhead to a
spear
and you're thinking i'm smarter than
that like you're not you know that that
comes from the accumulation of life
experience accumulation of observation
and experience over many generations and
that's a little mini version of the
collective super intelligence it's like
you know it's equivalent of like making
a pencil today like
um
people back then like the the the
conventional wisdom like had this super
this this knowledge that no human could
ever accumulate so we're very wired to
trust it plus the secondary thing is
that the people who you know just say
that they believe the mountain is is
they worship the mountain is their god
right and the mountain determines their
fate that's not true right and the
conventional wisdom's wrong there but
um believing it was helpful to survival
because you were one you you you were
part of the crowd and you stayed in the
tribe and if you started to you know you
know insult their the mountain god and
say that's just a mountain it's not you
know you didn't fare very well right so
it was for a lot of reasons it was a
great survival trait to just trust what
other people said
uh and believe it and truly obviously
you know the more you really believed it
the better
today
um conventional wisdom
in a rapidly changing world
um and a huge
giant society our brains are not built
to understand that they have a few
settings you know and none of them is uh
you know 300 million person society so
they're so your brain is basically
um
uh
is treating a lot of things like a small
tribe even though they're not they're tr
and and they're treating conventional
wisdom as as you know very wise
in a way that it's not if you think
about it this way it's like a picture a
like a bucket that's not moving very
much moving like a millimeter a year and
so it has time to collect a lot of water
in it that's like conventional wisdom in
the old days when very few things change
like your your ten your
great-great-great-grandmother probably
lived a similar life to you maybe on the
same piece of land
and so old people really knew what they
were talking about today the bucket's
moving really quickly
and so you know the wisdom doesn't
accumulate but we think it does because
our brain settings doesn't have the oh
move you know quickly moving bucket uh
setting on it so um my grandmother
gives me advice all the time and
i have to decide is this so there are
certain things that are not changing
like relationships and love and loyalty
and things like this
her advice on those things i'll listen
to it all day she's one of the people
who said you got to live near you people
you love live near your family right i i
think that is like tremendous wisdom
right that is wisdom because that
happens to be something that hasn't
doesn't change from generation to
generation for now right she all right
for now she's also telling right so i'll
be the idiot tell me
that they'll actually be in some
metaverse like exactly it doesn't matter
and i'm like you have to it's not the
same when you're not in person they're
gonna say it it's exactly the same
and they'll also be thinking to me with
their link and i'm gonna be like slow
down i don't understand what you're
saying you just talk like a normal
anyway so so my grandmother then but
then she says you know you're i don't
know about this writing you're doing you
should go to law school and you know you
know you want to be secure and that's
not good advice for me you know given
the world i'm in and what i like to do
and what i'm good at uh that's not the
right advice but
because the the world is totally she's
in a different world so she became wise
for a world that's no longer here right
now if you think about that so then when
we think about conventional wisdom it's
a little like my grandmother and and um
there's a lot of no it's not maybe you
know 60 years outdated like her software
it's maybe 10 years outdated
conventional wisdom sometimes 20. so
anyway i think that we all continually
don't have the the confidence in our own
reasoning when it conflicts with what
everyone else thinks when with what
seems right uh we don't have the um the
guts to act on that reasoning for that
reason right you know um we we and so
there's so many elon examples i mean
just from the beginning building zip2
was his first company
and um
it was internet advertising at the time
when people said
you know this internet was brand new
like kind of like kind of thinking of
like the metaverse vr metaverse today
and people being like oh we're you know
we you know we still facilitate internet
advertising people are saying yeah
people are going to advertise on the
internet yeah right but actually
it wasn't that he's magical and saw the
future is that he looked at the present
looked at what the internet was
thought about you know the obvious like
advertising opportunity this was gonna
be uh it wasn't rocket science it wasn't
genius i don't believe i think it was
just seeing the truth and when everyone
else is laughing saying well you're
you're wrong i mean
i did the math and here it is right next
company you know x.com which became
eventually paypal um
people say oh yeah people gonna put
their financial information on the
internet no way
get to us it seems so obvious if you
went back then you would probably feel
the same way you'd think this is that is
a that is a fake company that no it's
just obviously not a good idea he looked
around and said you know i see where
this is and so again he could see where
it was going because he could see what
it was that day and not what it you know
not people conventional wisdom was still
a bunch of years earlier
uh spacex is the ultimate example a
friend of his apparently bought actually
compiled a
montage video montage of rockets blowing
up to show him this is not a good idea
and if but just even the bigger picture
the amount of billionaires who have like
thought this was i'm gonna
start launching rockets and you know the
amount that failed i mean it's it's not
conventional wisdom said this isn't a
bad endeavor he was putting all of his
money into it yeah landing rockets was
another thing you know well if you know
here's the classic kind of way we are we
reason which is
if this could be done nasa would have
done it a long time ago because of the
money it would save this could be done
the soviet union would have done it back
in the 60s uh it's it's obviously
something that can't be done and
the math on his envelope said well i
think it can be done and so he just did
it so in each of these cases i think
actually in some ways elon gets too much
credit as you know people think it's
it's that he's you know it's that his
einstein intelligence or his he can see
the future he has incredible uh he has
incredible guts he's so you know
courageous i think if you actually are
looking at reality
uh and you're just assessing
probabilities and you're ignoring all
the noise which is wrong so wrong right
and you just
then you just have to be you know pretty
smart and you know pretty courageous um
and you have to have this magical
ability to be seen and trust your
reasoning over conventional wisdom
because your individual reasoning
you know part of it is that we we see
that we can't build a pencil we can't
build you know this civilization on our
own right we it's so so we we we kind of
count you know doubt to the um
to the collective
because for good reasons but this is
different when it comes to kind of
what's possible you know the beatles
were doing their kind of motowny chord
patterns in the early 60s and they they
were doing what was normal they were
doing what was clearly this kind of
sound is a hit
then they started getting weird because
they had they were so popular they had
this confidence to say let's just we're
going to start just experimenting
and it turns out that like
if you're just all these people are in
this like one groove together doing
music and it's just like there's a lot
of land over there
and it seems like you know i'm sure the
managers would say and that the the all
the record execs are saying no you have
to be here this is what sells and it's
just not true
so i think that elon is like but the the
term for this that actually elon likes
to use is reasoning from first
principles the physics term uh first
principles are your axioms and
physicists they don't say well what's
you know what what's what do people
think no they say what are the axioms
those are the puzzle pieces let's use
those to build a conclusion that's our
hypothesis now let's test it right and
and they come up with all kinds of new
things constantly by doing that
if einstein was was assuming
conventional wisdom was right he never
would have even tried to create
something that really disproved newton's
laws and the other way to reason is
reasoning by analogy which is a
uh great shortcut it's it's when we look
at other people's reasoning and we kind
of photocopy it into our head we steal
it
so uh reasoning by analogy we do all the
time and it's usually a good thing i
mean we don't if you it takes a lot of
mental energy and time to reason from
first principles it's actually you know
you don't want to reinvent the wheel
every time right you want to often copy
uh other people's reasoning most of the
time and i you know most of us do it
most of the time and that's good but
there's certain moments when you forget
just for a second like succeeding in
like the world of like elon
just who you're going to marry where are
you going to settle down how are you
going to raise your kids
how are you going to educate your kids
how you should educate yourself what
kind of career paths and turns these
moments this is what on your death bed
like you look back on and that's what
these are these
few number of choices that really define
your life those should not be reasoned
by analogy you should absolutely try to
reason from first principles and elon
not just by the way in his work but in
his personal life i mean if you just
look at the way he's on twitter he's not
it's not how you're supposed to be when
you're a super famous uh you know
you know industry titan you're not
supposed to just be silly on twitter and
do memes and and get in little little
quibbles with you
he just does things his own way
regardless of what you're supposed to do
which sometimes serves him and sometimes
doesn't but
i think
it has taken him where it has taken
you